president Trump is keeping a promise he
made to religious leaders months ago on
Friday he issued two directives on
religious liberty one which allows more
employers to opt out of covering birth
control for workers the other that could
weaken protections for LGBT Americans
all of this as mr. Trump has still not
explained a cryptic an ominous comment
he made earlier this week
Errol Barnett is at the White House Erol
good morning good morning the White
House issued what you could describe as
a one-two punch yesterday in the name of
religious freedom this as the
administration refuses to shed any light
on a presidential riddle the President
believes that the freedom to practice
one's faith is a fundamental right in
this country the White House cited
religious freedom in issuing new
guidelines to allow employers with
religious or moral conviction to opt out
of the Obamacare mandate requiring
health insurance to cover birth control
some women's rights groups are
threatening legal action and it's really
prioritizing a certain religious view
about contraception over a woman's own
personal beliefs another ruling could
override anti-discrimination protection
for LGBT people by allowing religious
employers to hire only persons whose
beliefs and conducts are consistent with
those of the company and in the midst of
these major domestic rollbacks president
Trump set off a global guessing game
what did you mean by calm before the
storm you'll find out
president Trump hadn't tweeted in over
24 hours last night after he again
teased reporters and the world about a
coming storm say that he's messing with
the press as for just what the coming
storm may be White House spokesperson
Sarah Sanders refused to clarify I think
we have some serious world issues here
it began after a presidential dinner
Thursday night with top military leaders
and their wives when President Trump
said this
before that meeting President Trump said
tremendous progress had been made
against Isis amid rising tension with
North Korea and ahead of next week's
announcement of the president's 'iron
strategy we have had challenges that we
really should have taken care of a long
time ago
the president is expected to take steps
next week that could unravel the
agreement to freeze Iran's nuclear
program that action would be in defiance
of top national security advisers like
defense secretary Jim mattis and
Secretary of State Rex Tillerson
president Trump refuted reports this
week that Tillison called him a [ __ ]
and nearly quit following a July meeting
at the Pentagon to his fake news who was
a totally phony story now in an
impromptu press conference on Wednesday
the press averse secretary of state said
he has no plans to exit but he did not
deny calling the president a name the
White House says the president remains
confident in Tillison Anthony Errol
Barnett at the White House thanks Errol